derek zoolander yes Valentina Valencia
Interpol global fashion division fashion
police were clean lady go harass
somebody else besides I'm out of fashion
I need to talk to you it has to do with
the death of Justin Bieber this death is
not my problem I can use the database
and Interpol to help you find your son
if you help me
I think we got to play ball with her
she's got some kind of database or
something that she says will help us
find old Eric
and she's hot I trust her if Tom text
you which he went cuz I still daylight
wait for hours to respond I was not even
Fanny boom Sunnah implies that you're
needy and really codependent and
incapable of a simple hookup which is
all he's good for I think that I could
actually be like and when you respond do
not respond in full sentences and if you
use an emoji
I won't tip punchy no no no you can have
this back at the end of the day emoji oh
this is the Hall of Heroes home with the
most priceless kung fu artifacts in all
of China whoa this is awesome where you
can say awesome right cuz it don't but
be super careful everything's very
fragile here like the urn of whispering
warriors someone broke that once who
some idiot check it out it's the
legendary battle rich off emperor hawk
yeah what are you doing we're not
supposed to touch anything oh sorry
sorry should I put it back yeah you
probably should you look so cool though
yeah it's pretty cool Oh what this does
I should pull it
I think I just peed a little
X no give it to your mom wait for you to
get it on your own national delivered
for Lucas you gonna do a superhero
laughing wait for it
whoa superhero landing yeah that's
really hard on your knees totally
impractical I'll do it you're a lovely
lady but I'm saving myself for Francis
that's why I brought him I'd prefer not
to hit a woman
so please
I mean that's why I brought her oh no
finish your tweet it's not just give us
a second
there you go hashtag it okay so pity the
dude who pressures her into prom sex